digamos que este personaje que se
encuentra aquí soy yo y que me encuentro
a la deriva en el espacio a velocidad
constante respecto a cualquier otro
sistema de referencia inercial entonces
de esta forma yo mismo puedo ser digamos
un sistema de referencia inercial y voy
a definir mi marco de referencia por mí
mismo es decir yo voy a hacer el origen
de mi marco de referencia verdad
entonces así en cualquier tiempo yo seré
digamos estacionario y estaré en el
punto x igual a cero entonces solo me
voy a concentrar en una dimensión para
simplificar la discusión muy bien
entonces ahora lo que he dibujado aquí
son dos ejes son unos ejes para poder
graficar la trayectoria de las cosas a
medida que el tiempo avanza en mi marco
de referencia y algo que quizás ya
habrás notado es que graficado el tiempo
en el eje vertical y la posición x en
digamos está la voy a medir en metros
verdad en el eje horizontal y eso quizás
sea anti intuitivo verdad de hecho es
es un poco incómodo para mí debo
confesarlo yo yo la verdad lo prefiero
al revés pero en realidad la elección de
los ejes y de cómo los ponemos pues
siempre ha sido arbitraria verdad
digamos nosotros solemos pensar que la
posición está dirigida por el tiempo
verdad pero pero a medida que avancemos
en estos temas podremos pensar que la
posición es la que dirige al tiempo pero
bueno ya llegaremos a eso así que cuál
sería mi posición en este diagrama en
cada momento del tiempo bueno notemos
que en el eje vertical tenemos el tiempo
y vamos 123 segundos en el eje
horizontal tenemos 3 por 10 a la 8 6 por
10 al 8 9 por 10 a la 8 metros y por
supuesto todo esto viene de la noción de
la velocidad de la luz que es
aproximadamente de 3 por 10 a la 8
metros sobre segundo verdad es la
velocidad aproximada de la luz verdad
entonces si nosotros queremos graficar
cómo me muevo yo a lo largo del tiempo y
del espacio pues simplemente vemos qué
cuando te vale 0 cuando te vale 0 la
posición en la que me encuentro es
justamente 0 pero si avanza un segundo
entonces nuevamente estamos en la
posición 0 porque dijimos que iba a
hacer estacionario verdad lo mismo si
pasan 2 segundos o si pasan 3 segundos
entonces en este sentido mi trayectoria
mi trayectoria sería más o menos así
verdad esta sería mi trayectoria porque
a medida que avance el tiempo siempre me
queda en la misma posición y dijimos que
iba a ser la posición cero esa sería mi
trayectoria en este diagrama
espacio-temporal verdad ahora pensemos
en algo interesante digamos que yo llevo
digamos aquí una linterna que digamos
que llevo una linterna y digamos también
que
en el tiempo te iguala 0 enciendo esta
linterna muy bien entonces al tiempo t
igual a cero enciendo la linterna
fijémonos qué es lo que pasa con el
primer fotón de luz emitida entonces
vamos a graficar también su trayectoria
en este en este diagrama verdad y
digamos que este fotón se mueve en la
dirección horizontal verdad de hecho en
la dirección positiva a lo largo del eje
horizontal o del eje x y vamos a suponer
que se mueve a velocidad constante sé
que es la velocidad de la luz verdad
entonces al tiempo cero se encuentra
justamente donde estoy yo verdad aquí
estaría después de un segundo se
encuentra justamente en tres por 10 a la
8 metros ahora qué pasa después de dos
segundos pues de dos segundos después de
dos segundos se encuentra en la posición
de 6 por 10 a la 8 metros verdad
entonces la trayectoria simplemente
hacerlo un poquito más grueso verdad por
supuesto esto no quedó preciso por
debido a que lo estoy haciendo a mano
verdad pero más o menos se vería de esta
forma y uno pensaría que es una recta de
45 grados pero en realidad esto es un es
un efecto en la escala que yo di en los
ejes verdad así que no perdamos de vista
eso
y solo para para repasar verdad aquí a
un segundo estaremos en tres por diez a
la ocho en dos segundos estaremos en
seis por diez a la ocho entre segundos
estaremos en nueve por diez a la ocho
verdad eso digamos eso es como el avance
de ese fotón a lo largo del tiempo y del
espacio muy bien así que vamos a quitar
todo esto entonces hasta aquí parece
bastante interesante todo esto nos
estamos digamos acostumbrando a ver el
diagrama de esta forma verdad con los
ejes digamos invertidos pero ahora vamos
a introducir a otro personaje que
también pueda definir su propio marco de
referencia entonces digamos que justo al
tiempo cero hay una nave espacial que
pasa justo por encima de mí digamos esta
nave espacial muy rara y digamos que hay
una amiga mía que se encuentra sobre de
ella de hecho ella digamos es
estacionaria sobre esa nave espacial muy
bien muy bien entonces digamos que esta
nave además va muy rápido esta nave se
dirige en la dirección positiva a lo
largo de gamos del eje x verdad digamos
en la dirección horizontal y digamos que
lleva una velocidad de 0.5 la velocidad
de la luz es decir la mitad de la
velocidad de la luz muy bien entonces en
resumen mi amiga es estacionaria en la
nave la nave se mueve a esa velocidad
constante de 0.5 c en la dirección
positiva del eje x lo cual hace que
estén en un sistema de referencia
inercial verdad así que graphic hemos su
trayectoria en mi diagrama muy bien
vamos a pensar que justo al tiempo t
igual a 0 estaba justo arriba de donde
estaba yo verdad entonces se encuentra
en la misma posición después de un
segundo
y se encontrará en 1.5 por 10 a la 8
metros verdad porque va a la mitad de la
velocidad de la luz ahora bien después
de dos segundos se encontrará a 3 por 10
a la 8 metros es decir después de dos
segundos se encontrará en la misma
posición que digamos la luz después de
un segundo verdad entonces después de
tres segundos se encontrará en 4.5 por
10 a la 8 metros y ahora vamos a trazar
esa trayectoria en nuestro diagrama y
más o menos se vería algo así dejen de
pintar la mejor más o menos se vería
algo así recordemos que pues como esto
está hecho a mano no se ve muy preciso
verdad entonces ahora lo que me gustaría
que hicieras a continuación es que
pienses lo que representan estas dos
líneas que al menos te familiarices con
los ejes que por ejemplo el digamos el
tiempo t
y ahora en el eje vertical lo que vamos
a ver en el siguiente vídeo o más bien
vamos a usar justamente esto que he
dibujado para ahora dibujar el diagrama
de espacio-tiempo para el marco de
referencia de mi amiga que se encuentra
sobre esta nave espacial verdad y lo
vamos a dibujar sobre este diagrama que
ya hemos puesto aquí y para fines de
todos estos vídeos vamos a suponer que
vivimos en un mundo newtoniana por ahora
no llegaremos a einstein y la
relatividad especial